the Joe Rogan experience I know a lady
who lives in the Arctic Circle she lives
like 200 miles above the Arctic Circle
she's on that show life below zero you
ever see that show but she can come out
when she wants she can come back she
flies back she was in the studio not
this one the old one but she was sitting
right where you're sitting like you know
she's a normal person I can't even take
a cruise
no no but you were gonna cruise in the
Congo that's a river but I can't take a
cruise boat because I can't be isolated
in the middle of the ocean with people I
don't think are really on the ball like
I can't do it I think that's where like
the next plague starts I think does
happen sometimes
yeah they get the norovirus or whatever
on a cruise ship what if someone's just
really into chucking people over the
side like that's your move you just take
a cruise I like those people that
survive that I like the stories of the
people that cruise ship really and they
get found who [ __ ] finds them they're
in a shipping lane they get found really
I love those stories I've never heard
those doors I always thought your [ __ ]
you imagine would you like almost
nothing that can [ __ ] you worse than to
fall off a cruise ship but these people
they they survive it you have to think
of how long can you swim right I mean
it's like 13 hours or tread water well
you can tread water longer than that
sure you can I sing like a rock you'll
be hallucinating right but used to be
training water you just be your tissue
be tearing apart what I heard one guy
talk about was how he saw like you know
he had the illusion of seeing boats come
by and talk to him and he like talked to
people that were saying just hang on
hang on longer who's all imaginary like
none of it was real but he was having
like a full sort of trippy virtual
reality experience with his
hallucinations that kept him alive
longer they were like his subconscious
but they would come in his mind in
vessels and like stop and talk to him
throw him something motivate him that's
crazy I guess you could get that if you
go know one of those um sensory
deprivation tanks or something like oh
you do I one right over here shut up
[ __ ] yeah Wow
well do you do that regularly yeah do
you have a loose Nations yeah
that's why tell me the most extreme one
I was in the jungle and there was some
people that were native to this place
they were dressed in western clothes
they like t-shirts and shorts but they
were barefoot
which is often the case though
unfortunately a lot of people that live
in these indigenous villages they wear
like Under Armor shirts and [ __ ] that
they someone gets them somehow it gets
down to them missionaries maybe
sometimes bring them but they were
speaking in a language that I understood
but it was in English and I don't speak
anything other than English and when
they were talking I was listening to
them I was amongst them and I was
listening to them and they were speaking
in this very different language and then
I realized like holy [ __ ] I can
understand their language but I realized
that in English and then poof I popped
out of the spell like my freaking out
about it
brought me what it was all like don't
know don't go away don't go away ah [ __ ]
it's like it was so extreme it was I
could smell the the rain I could feel
the moisture in the air I could see the
leaves all around me I could hear the
sounds of the forest and these people in
the rainforest
just hanging out talking this it was
totally uneventful nothing was happening
but they were talking in this language
that I absolutely knew what they were
saying they were going back and forth
and communicating and I was following
the conversation in their language
thinking in their language and then I
realized that and I woke up how do you
interpret that I think first of all was
tripping balls right there's that
there's being in that tank on what I
think it was edible pot I've done a
bunch of different things in the tank
but mostly it's edible pot pot edibles
has a distinctly hallucinatory effect at
high doses
especially when you close your eyes and
you're laying back and just like just
just letting visuals take place also I
think it's entirely possible that we
have genetic memory and I think it's
entirely possible that
like there's certain things that people
pass down to their children like there's
certain traits that my kids have that I
watching them and I go okay how do you
why are you so into this are you so into
this because you just happened to be
into this are you into this because you
because I'm into this and some are
another got into my jeans and passed on
to your little tiny body and now you're
developing with this like hunger for
certain certain types of activities so
literally in their cellular level of you
know we don't know what's transferred we
don't know how much of like what looks
people have certain instincts right
people are afraid of spiders are afraid
of snakes why why is that it's probably
some memory probably somewhere along the
line some memory got transferred into
your DNA
well the question is like how much gets
in there until I told my nine-year-old
daughter I'd I thought probably very
little I was probably just like physical
traits and that's it but her mind is so
much like my mind like and especially
her obsession with things I've never
seen a little kid so obsessed with
things like this is me and a
nine-year-old girl's body like this is
[ __ ] crazy and talking to people that
have musical talent or people that have
artistic talent and their children seem
to have an aptitude for this like an
unusual aptitude almost as if they're
trying to remember it rather than learn
it oh I like what you just said I like
that's immature I think there's
something that gets Trent I don't I
don't know how much of it is readable
data but I think there's so much
information that gets through your cells
and then I think the child is faced with
their own data right their own life
experiences their own genetics their own
hormones and all these different things
that are happening around them but I
think underneath all that it's entirely
possible that remains some very very
distant memories which is why people
survived as long as they did because you
could transfer some knowledge unto the
kids okay it's probably less today than
before because the world the world so
safe everything's nerfed you know if to
worry about getting eaten by leopards
like it's it's a totally different
environment we live in it so less of it
gets in there but I think there's
probably still somewhere in the
operating system if you went into das
and start sneaking
you'd find some weird code from like
different languages that you spoke
10,000 years ago or you know who knows
whatever life expect why are kids scared
of monsters those are another thing that
they were talking about one someone
these things like they're scared of
monsters because monsters used to be a
real thing that you had to worry about
cuz they ate people like cats like
leopards and jaguars and [ __ ] like that
was a real problem so little kids
they're not scared of bullets or you
know they're scared of [ __ ] monsters
that's what every little kids scared of
the dark and monsters because that's in
our genetic memory probably some
leftover [ __ ] from when we got eaten a
lot in trees yeah trees right so falling
and predation
yeah both
[Applause]